[Music]
as omicron concerns continue thousands
of unlv students headed back to class
today unlike during the fall semester a
vaccine mandate is not in place joe
moeller spoke to students today he joins
us live on campus with what they had to
share joe
occasionally it was a pretty busy day
here on the unlv campus just behind us
here some students are actually leaving
for the day we talked to a handful of
them most of them feel pretty safe with
the precautions in place but some would
like to see that mandate back in place
students are back on campus for spring
semester 2022 about 40 percent of
classes remain virtual during the fall
semester a vaccine mandate for students
was in place that came to an end after
the legislative commission said it was
not permanent with a recent spike in
cases students still feel comfortable as
more than 90 percent of them are all
vaccinated me and my family got the
vaccine so i'm
good on all that if no people don't want
to get then it's fine it's up to them
one of my professors already threatened
us that if we don't wear a mask during
an exam or like we don't wear it in his
class he will kick us at like by the
second time he warns us friday the board
of regents sent a letter to lawmakers
pushing for a mandate to be put in place
back out here live it is up to the board
of health to make the mandate i checked
into that there is currently no public
hearing scheduled on that topic as of
now but there is still that vaccine
mandate in place for staff here on
campus reporting live at unlv joe mohler
live local now thank you